there's a lot
different to do in the night than it is
during the day I like the natural light
so I've been flowing a lot and
there's a lot that's coming out and it
feels like it's coming from the void and
it's very beautiful
and it's very direct
and it doesn't care for the ego
of course the void has no charge
expressing itself as charge and polarity
but really there is no polarity
but there is a repelling or distaste for
ego
ego is like molasses it has a high
viscosity it's
thick and it's it permeates the space
with
its own
sense of self and its own image and
concerns about its attachments and
just I endless narcissistic oriented
things
and then no self which has no charge at
all
and just sits there and watches the self
be totally
because the self can't see itself but no
self can see self
and so and self can't see no self of
course
even though no self is what's giving
rise to self
and so no self sits there looking at
self which is itself and looking and
being like
is that
a 10 year old in a 38 year old's body
and the answer is yes it is
it is
it's someone that never outgrew
childhood that is inside of an adult
body
which is the vast majority of society
stupid
immersed in their character which is
what the point of reality is in a way
but to such degree that
endless suffering happens
which is
of course happening to no one
but at the same time
there is a recipe
there's a solution there's a way to stop
suffering
learning what's before your mask
what is underneath of your character
identity
and you can say that it's the same
infinite Consciousness which is no one
and everyone and you can get really
conceptual about it
but most it matters for you to have
direct experience of it
that there is nobody but you
when you deconstruct your false self
to separate segregated self
you find the true self
which is no self
there's nobody behind any eyes
that's the greatest
healing that's the greatest love
that's the greatest way to
exist is from non-existence
until you taste that your sense of self
does not exist
you will create molasses and viscosity
in the flow of infinity
and people wearing their masks will not
be able to tell because they come from
the same place
their own sense of lack of unholeness
unworthiness constantly trying to get
validation seek approval
but no self can tell it's viscous
and it's
it's thick and it permeates the space in
such a
it is disgusting it really is disgusting
and I came from the same place
so I know
the way I came off when I talked to
people
to myself which I didn't know was myself
and so I was talking to people trying to
extract things out of them all the time
and so when you directly experience no
self
you stop
seeing separation you stop feeling
separation
you stop trying to extract things out of
yourself
you can only see yourself everywhere
so nobody is everywhere
and that is perfection
so that's why the charge goes away
that's why it's said that there's
nothing to do
if you know you're nobody
and you don't have charge because
everything's perfect
then you can sit
in complete non-existence while existing
and feel total absolute perfection
that everything is literally the same
infinite agent that is nobody and
everybody
that's all for now